and then somewhat surreally it was
business as usual a meet and greet with
pakistan's president as though he hadn't
just authorized what could be the
biggest military invasion since world
war ii and justified it as though he was
taking on nazi germany
how far is vladimir putin prepared to go
in ukraine do you think pure separation
is
crushing aviation and the identity of
this house system
also then
[Music]
ukrainian army should be
surrounded and
disarmed
all neo-nazi groups
i think should be
crashed uh and formation of new uh uh
system of power i suppose that uh
zerensky will leave keep in
a couple of days from
now
decisive and immediate action was needed
the state newscasters say against
ukrainian aggression they insist
as footage shows fighters on the front
line declaring they'll take this land
[Applause]
and many people back home believe the
narrative
received
[Music]
and he said over and over again that he
had no intention of invading and now
he's invading what do you make of that
well
he has to react he has to he has to he
has to help the people in the in the
rambast region
i would say
he is by saying that he's not intending
to invade his meaning
it means that he's not intending to
occupy
but public opinion's a mixed bag
it's
awful and i'm really sorry it's and it's
really really sad but i can't do with
this nothing
yeah
we can only sorry
in the kremlin vladimir putin met his
key businessman to work through how to
weather the sanctioned storm
western leaders have tried to emphasize
that they have no quarrel with the
russian people the trouble is the
long-term economic consequences of the
squeeze of the toughest sanctions the
west can muster will be felt by the
people and that will most likely
consolidate anti-western sentiment which
is pretty strong as it is
[Applause]
and there are plenty who don't like
what's happening here anti-war protests
in more than 20 cities across russia
swiftly shut down by police with more
than a thousand detained
no war with ukraine this sign says
but it's too late for that
donna mcnay sky news moscow